ويفاربيل قدام
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
في السنوات الاخيره تحول هذا الرجل الى
محور الحراك في الحزب الجمهوري الرئيس
السابق دونالد ترامب تسببت سياساته وخطبه
في انشقاقات عميقه في الحزب الجمهوري
جديد جديد
اليوم السادس من يناير من عام 2021 عندما
اقتحم المئات من انصارهم مبنى الكونجرس
رافضين نتائج الانتخابات الرئاسيه التي
اطاحت بالترامب لصالح منافسه الديمقراطي
قائمه خصومه ترامب داخل الحزب الجمهوري
زادت بعد احداث الكونجرس التي اداناها عدد
من قاده الحزب بل ويدوا اجراء تحقيقات في
حق ترامب بشان دوره في التحريض عليها
قائمه خصومه ترامب من الجمهوريين تشمل
سيناتور ميتروني عن ولايته وهو ايضا
المرشح الخاسر في انتخابات الرئاسه لعام
2012 امام الرئيس السابق باراك اوباما لفت
الروم للانتباها اليه حين اصبح سيناتور
الوحيد الذي يصوت ضد رئيس من حزمه في
محاكمه عزل ترامب عام 2020 وتلقى حين ها
ده فعل غاضبه من زملائه الجمهوريه هناك
ايضا عضو مجلس النواب عن ولايه وايمان
بليز تشيني احدى عشر سنين ترامب شغلت منصب
نائب رئيس اللجنه التي شكلها الكونغرس
للتحقيق في احداث السادس من يناير عقبها
ترامب بدعم منافساتها في الانتخابات
التمهيديه في الولايه هاريت هايمان فخسرت
تشين فرصتها في الترشح مجددا لمجلس النواب
وايضا هناك النائب الجمهوري ادم كنزنجر
عضو اخر في لجنه التحقيق ضد ترامب وعرف
بدعمه لمرشحين الديمقراطيين يواجهون
مرشحين من الجمهوريين يدعمه
قراره بعدم الترشح لاعاده انتخابه اثار
التكهنات ان الاسباب وراء ذلك هي مخاوف
وكنزنجر من ان يواجه ذات المصير الذي لحق
بزميلاته تشيني
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
في عام 2021 دعت سيناتور الجمهوريه
المعتدله عن الاشكال ليز موركوفسكي ترامب
للاستقاله بعد اعمال العنف التي شهدها مقر
الكونجرس وكانت حينها اول عضو جمهوريه في
مجلس الشيوخ يطالب بذلك لم ينسى لها ترامب
موقفها ورد لها الضربه هذا العام بدعمه
كيليتش باكا وبذلك فتحت المعارك التي
يخوضها ترامب داخل حزب الجمهوري واختلاف
الحسابات والمصالح بينهم باب الانقسام
داخل الحزب
هاتف
[موسيقى]